und damit ganz herzlich willkommen sehr
geehrte damen und herren hier in nrw
nicht sehr geehrte damen und herren so
geht das nicht
das sagt man nicht mehr patricia
zumindest nicht bei der lufthansa die
lufthansa findet sehr geehrte damen und
herren in diesen ansagen die wir alle so
lieben bei der lufthansa nicht mehr
gender gerecht da würde nicht jeder
angesprochen sagt die lufthansa also weg
weg weg damit raus aus der sprache nix
mit sehr geehrte damen und herren hat
man sich da dann immer so aufgehoben und
sicher gefühlt seit jahrzehnten höheren
semestern weiß wenn es geht jetzt gleich
los ich weiß auch wer gemeint ist
nämlich vorbei ist es ja nicht mehr
verweise ist damit der überblick über
diesen fall
hören sie jetzt einmal ganz genau hin
denn sätze wie diesen werden sie
zumindest bei lufthansa nie wieder hören
denn liebe damen und herren herzlich
willkommen auf unseren flug nach
frankfurt
die gender polizei hat mal wieder
zugeschlagen
lufthansa lenkt ein und trennt sich von
der altbekannten begrüßung der autobauer
audi nennt seine mitarbeiter nur noch
audi jahnerinnen und löst damit einen
shitstorm im internet aus
[Musik]
zdf hauptstadtkorrespondenten nicole
diekmann zeigte eindrucksvoll wie wir
ihrer meinung nach in zukunft
miteinander sprechen sollten natürlich
unternehmer erinnern
wissenschaftler/innen politiker innen
intensivmediziner innen beziehungsweise
mediziner in den forschern die insel
bewohner innen wie die vielen pendler
innere noch lange nicht so wie der hier
der geschlechter forscher lang
hornscheidt fordert zum schutz vor
diskriminierung statt der oder die nur
noch eins zu sagen das klingt dann so
evans und enns einkaufskorb und deswegen
heißt es auch bei den lufthanseaten
künftig nur noch gute norden musste es
da nicht gästen
man weiß es ich es habe ich immer gesagt
jugendlichen ins trudeln sie hat neun
falsch verwendet das bild chef julian
reichelt jugend darf man zudem noch herr
reichelt sagen oder was habe ich mir
dann sagen aber ist keine förderung
julia und sagen da schon erreicht sagen
ich fühle mich da relativ klar
zugeordnet und ich glaube das ist ja
auch das worum es hier geht natürlich
gibt es menschen die sich bei sehr
geehrte damen und herren nicht
angesprochen fühlen
dann ist aber die frage wie viele von
dieser ohnehin sehr sehr sehr kleinen
gruppe fühlen sich dadurch verletzt dass
irgendjemand sehr geehrte damen und
herren sagt ich wollte mit 13 14 pilot
werden wegen dieser satz ist gut wieder
sehr geehrte damen und herren guten
morgen aus dem cockpit ja ich glaube
dieser teil von menschen sich verletzt
fühlen weil ein pilot sack auf höfliche
weise sehr geehrte damen und herren der
existiert so gut wie nicht statistisch
und die frage ist müssen wir wirklich
unsere ganze sprache in zukunft unser
leben unsere art und weise miteinander
umzugehen das war s für unseren kindern
erzählen ja es gibt nämlich tatsächlich
damen und herren daran ausrichten dass
irgendjemand sich auf 24 c verletzt
fühlen könnte von sehr geehrte damen und
herren ich sage ganz klar nein ich habe
sogar noch eine weitere these die
nächste bundestagswahl wird gewinnen wer
auf die frage wieviel geschlechter gibt
es ganz eindeutig antwortet 2 im übrigen
trifft das ja auch millionen kinder
ganze generationen von kindern die er
auch über jahrzehnte von der lufthansa
nicht angesprochen wurden ich würde für
meine kinder in anspruch nehmen
sie fühlten sich auf diesen flügen nie
verletzt mit sehr geehrte damen und
herren und wurden die auch gleichermaßen
nicht angesprochen wir müssen sowieso
uns glaube ich die frage stellen ist das
potenzielle risiko dass sich irgendwer
auf der welt verletzt fühlen könnte und
die unterstellung dass sich da ganz
sicher jemand verletzt fühlen wird
tatsächlich das woran wir ja unser leben
ausrichten sollen die erziehung unserer
kinder ausrichten sollen ich würde sogar
noch weiter gehen ich glaube tatsächlich
wenn man sich comedy anschauen wenn man
sich stand aber anschaut wenn man sich
leicht anhört wenn man sich medien
anschaut wenn man sich boulevard antwort
es gibt sogar in der verfassungsmäßig
garantierten im verfassungs garantierte
recht auf meinungsäusserung
ausdrucksfreiheit gibt es natürlich auch
das recht mal jemanden vor den kopf zu
stoßen ja und ich glaube auch nicht dass
wir unseren kindern sagen sollten du
hast es verdient in einer welt in der
die ja nie eine kränkung widerfahren
wird in der dich niemals jemand verletzt
wird in der jeder immer alles
berücksichtigt wird was wichtig wird das
ist nicht die welt was wir dort
vermitteln ist falsch und wie es sich
aus merkt man leider bei einem
unternehmen bei dem ich stammkunden
stammkunde bleiben werde aber mit
sicherheit etwas sehr vermissen werde
nämlich guten morgen sehr geehrte damen
und herren aus dem komplett unsere leser
also auch unsere zuschauer sie regt
dieses thema besonders auf ganz ganz
viele briefe haben uns erreicht wir
haben einige hier vorliegen denn nicht
jeder ist nicht so sicher dass er weiter
mit der lufthansa fliegen will denn für
viele ist klar das ist absoluter irrsinn
peter es schreibt zum beispiel für mich
ist das ein triftiger grund nicht mehr
mit lufthansa zu fliegen diese
gottverdammte den reihen das ganze getue
drumherum ist einfach unerträglich ich
boykottiere grundsätzlich jeder und
alles was in diesem zusammenhang schule
dieter kaden schreibt uns und ich habe
geglaubt die lufthansa hätte im moment
andere probleme und dafür fast zehn
milliarden steuergelder bekommen
das geht weiter auch dieter k schreibt
uns wie es geht noch der letzte anstand
verloren mich ärgert dass man von
einigen firmen am telefon oder in
briefen geduzt wird also das ist
offenbar auch etwas womit man viele
menschen die viel mehr verletzen und
treffen kann indem man ganz schnell
und wie vom höflichen sie auf so
wechselt und sagt mein studio ist eine
falsche bestellung abgegeben
dann wird eine beschwerde e mail also an
do muss ich sagen habe ich mich
inzwischen gewöhnt ich finde es gibt
durchaus auch dinge bei denen man
sozusagen den gesellschaftlichen wandel
auch den wandel von sprache durchaus
anerkennen kann ohne daraus gleich eine
grundsatzdebatte zu machen aber
interessanter punkt von unserem
zuschauer
diese änderung der deutschen sprache
sehr geehrte damen und herren die es nun
einmal gibt wird ihnen präsentiert von
zehn milliarden euro deutsches
steuergeld das ist das was wir dafür
jetzt bekommen noch was interessant
gottfried w schreibt jetzt ist dieser
gender wahnsinn also auch bei der
lufthansa angekommen und er schreibt
hoffentlich machen andere airlines
diesen schwachsinn diesen gender
schwachsinn nicht mit das wird jetzt
interessant ob das stilprägend ist das
ist ja fast zu befürchten dass der trend
um sich kite oder glaubst du einzelne
airlines werden sie werden jetzt sagen
mini wir nehmen das von der lufthansa
die alten allem sagen und machen damit
möglicherweise sogar werbung
ich habe das gefühl dass dieses dieses
dringende bedürfnis bloß alles zu tilgen
zu streichen und auszuradieren was
irgendwen auf der welt irgendwie in
irgendeiner weise vielleicht vor den
kopf stoßen könnte dass das geradezu die
nächste epidemie nach grüner würden
sozusagen
deswegen ist meine prognose dass
lufthansa nicht das letzte unternehmen
sein wird was das streicht sondern dass
wir vermutlich das so bald nicht mehr
hören werden und dass ich dass wir das
nicht hören kann ist ja gar nicht das
thema das ist überhaupt kein problem das
problem ist was wird damit vermittelt es
wird damit doch vermittelt dass etwas
festzustellen was ist nun mal gibt auf
der welt was woran auch immer man glaubt
von gott bis evolution uns somit gegeben
wir das ist nunmal damen und herren auf
dieser welt gibt dass das ja auch nicht
schlecht ist für den fortbestand der
menschheit dass das in irgendeiner weise
das zu erwähnen eine verletzung sein
könnte
und ich glaube das ist eine geradezu
post faktische fakten fremde welt die
wir nicht durch unsere sprache und schon
gar nicht die steuergelder schaffen soll
ich freue mich auch immer wie weit er
wird das ganze gehen also werden vorher
auch so drüber diskutiert es heißt das
flugzeug unglück gehabt gott sei dank
aber der kranich der tomatensaft also wo
ziehen wir irgendwann auch die kleinen
boot holen oder airbus schon
gleichberechtigung hat sicherlich
gedacht wie ist es an bord zum beispiel
ist der beruf der stewardess gender
gerecht eigentlich nein das wort es tue
das ist ja schon lange versetzt worden
im alltag durch eine flugbegleiterin
flugbegleiter vermutlich aufgrund zu
vieler auch für den medien das muss man
auch an dem punkt vielleicht mal ganz
klar sagt durchaus betrieben das tor des
klischees in kunst kultur und medien
dafür stehe ich total den wandel den ist
da gibt der dass man sagt ich möchte
etwas was meinem selbstbild irgendwie
gerechter wird wenn ich diesen beruf aus
dem volles totales verständnis aber das
was mit unserer sprache gerade passiert
ist irgendwie erinnerte an das fast an
seinem roman an dem ansprache irgendwie
ausradiert und gepflegt werden soll was
der mensch ja nun mal ansprechen hat und
ich frag mich vor allem was passiert
eigentlich in zukunft wenn der
flugbegleiter oder die flugbegleiterin
jemanden einfach als herr oder frau
anspricht der manchmal wird man ja sogar
noch namentlich begrüßt im flugzeug aber
was ist denn wenn ich mich an dem tag
gar nicht als held fühlen sondern als
frau reichelt wie reagiert die lufthansa
darauf wollen sie in zukunft einfach
seinen guten morgen reichelt oder wollen
sie vielleicht am ende gar nicht mehr
guten morgen sagen das ist dann nämlich
das was am ende wird lass uns am ende
gar nicht mehr miteinander sprechen
damit sich bloß niemand gekränkt oder
verletzt führen könnte von unserer wort
1 habe ich noch nicht kapiert bei der
ganzen geschichte wie wird denn jetzt
eigentlich begrüßt also ein aber was ist
das neue das heißt nur noch herzlichen
guten morgen auch ladies und gentlemen
fällt weg aber da kann man sagen will
kann man baut die passengers nahm
englisch hat man es ja sehr viel
einfacher
dort wird tatsächlich auch bei der
lufthansa übrigen gehört ja auch swiss
und brussels airlines dazu also es ist
natürlich durch die star alliance
betrifft es durchaus einige flugzeuge in
denen man sitzen wird heißt es dann auch
ja guten morgen liebe gäste auch da
kommen natürlich wieder an einem punkt
vor einige sagen werden moment mal ist
muss heißen gästen also auch da ich
glaube in wonderland ja man muss es
wahrscheinlich einfach man muss jegliche
persönliche ansprache weglassen so
zumindest der plan der lufthansa und man
sagt einfach guten morgen und spricht
niemand mehr persönlich an
aus der sorge
etwas falsch zu machen wir bleiben an
diesem thema für sie dran zwar in
unserer neuen rubrik ihr sind des tages
neues von der sprachpolizei jeden tag
schauen wir ganz genau drauf was es in
diesen kosmos so neues gibt mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schau dich hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren